onions make you cry but this onion's
about to make you laugh
mortician always keeps hammer at table
side just in case one comes back to life
has that ever happened like i'm sure
there's some kind of crazy story and
what are you gonna do murder them
shouldn't you give them assistance dr
schulz introduces new amputation kit for
dry cracked feet touting the product's
ability to not only treat but also
prevent and remove the condition i added
the remove honestly my left foot i don't
know what it is i thought it was fungal
it's not really fungal i thought it was
like some kind of eczema thing it could
be it could be psoriasis i got a dry
cracked feet on my foot patients
impressed by how big baby has gotten
after just 16 months of crossfit whoa
that's a diesel baby we covered this on
strangest addictions with the family
like they work out a lot you know some
of it is really healthy but sometimes it
can be dangerous depending on the type
of exercise and the age of the child so
you got to be really careful and ask
your doctor for guidance in this
situation shortage of supplies force a
surgeon to wear boxing gloves for the
operation yes this is gonna be me in the
office one day boxing gloves would be
terrible for the operating room new
study finds most premature births occur
after fetus smells something delicious
outside that's such a funny image i
don't think that's why premature births
happen but we could put together a study
to find out imagine like you cook a
really good pie and then the baby's like
oh i got to come out now new fisher
price doctor kit just prescription pad
and bottles of
this fisher-price kit is severely
lacking we also prescribe other opioids
besides fentanyl
that's a joke humanitarian organization
doctors without dimensions faces into
war-torn non-linear universe i feel like
this is headlined by elon musk himself
how do you treat an alien when you don't
even know what's inside of them
surgeon totally blanks on what he cut
open patiently for
that's like surgeon says oops and
operating room is the last thing you
want to hear now why the hell did i make
this giant slit again said mitchell of
the six long transverse incision he made
across his subject's abdomen god i hope
this doesn't happen the onions guide to
hipaa you know what's funny i've been
seeing a lot of these tick tocks of
people just yelling hippa you cannot
record me that is against my hippo
you're in a hardware store hippa doesn't
apply here what is hipaa the reason you
have to sign up for some new website
ending in portal every time you go to a
different urgent care fact what does it
stand for health
information portability and
accountability act
is it health insurance or i think it's
health insurance
centers for disease control let smallpox
and
render pest viruses out for daily hours
exercise oh my god that sounds
frightening someone needs to tell me
what a rinder pest virus is and if you
know i'm gonna be impressed jimmy carter
already back to elite sumo wrestling
circuit after recovering from his
surgery what is this image i want to
learn more about sumo wrestling not
because of jimmy carter but because like
it has a rich history hospital adds
twenty thousand dollar scan that informs
patient whether they have features okay
this pokes at fun at the fact that a lot
of people order tests without any real
purpose you basically are just
confirming that the patient in fact has
bones if you just felt the patient's
anatomy and watched them walk and assess
their gait you would know the answer to
that question by the way if you didn't
know i'm going on tour boston philly red
bank new jersey and dc link down below
improv comedy games audience
participation you're gonna have a blast
i guarantee get your tickets now they're
selling out quickly all right let's get
back to it breakthrough procedure allows
surgeons to transplant pig rib directly
into human mouth that's funny because
you could have the surgeon make like
really nice cuts in it that would be
pretty tasty yup exercising woman really
starting to feel the burn of lifelong
injury developing oh yeah i'm definitely
starting to feel some results from my
repeated misuse of the treadmill and
poor running techniques nothing funny
about this because you cannot imagine
how often this happens even one of my
closest friends the other day pulled his
psoas muscle really badly because he
decided that it was cool to run at seven
miles per hour on the treadmill on like
a six incline for like five miles that's
not a smart play at least do intervals
where the treadmill goes up goes down
unless you're training for something
very specific and you're gradually
building up there the body's not ready
to handle that kind of load it's not
biomechanically friendly it will cause
pain man concerned that doctor wants to
discuss test results had more aggression
over the phone although he wasn't an
expert he had a bad feeling about the
physician's insistence on going over his
angiogram face to face while he was
lying down on a stainless steel table in
a facility full of dead bodies if your
doctor calls and asks you to have a
conversation face to face at the morgue
that should raise red flags effective
billboard has drivers suddenly craving
to visit the hospital where first class
care always comes first i'm not gonna
lie that the billboards that some
hospitals even ones that i've worked at
before are friggin weird i get what
they're doing they're trying to
encourage patients to come in and get
care and they're competing with other
health care systems and all of that i
hope what happens is patients are
alerted to the fact that they have a
facility near them where they can get
care in case of necessity conor mcgregor
undergoes three hours of surgery to
repair fractured ego oh my god that last
injury was the definition of a fractured
ego you could see by the way he acted
out in the octagon after the fact poor
class poor sportsmanship in my eyes
neurosurgeon holds spinal cord between
teeth to free up hands while performing
delicate incisions that's the worst
photoshop job i think i've ever seen in
my life i'm gonna go ahead and
accurately debunk why this is not good a
if you've removed the patient's entire
spine probably not compatible with
living unless it's a very unique
situation if you're gonna put the spine
back putting it in your mouth which is
potentially the dirtiest meaning most
bacteria rich filled area of your body
you probably don't want to put
back into the patient new haines
shapewear compresses women into
flattering trapezoids i don't understand
is this like a play on spanx eight and a
half month old fetus could really get
used to this man i gotta tell you this
is the life said the 37 week fetus i'm a
snug as a bug in a rug here but i've
still got enough room to turn a full 180
degrees plus there's this super fun
umbilical cord i can play with or wear
as a necklace don't wear it as a
necklace it's a big problem baby or
fetus gwyneth paltrow oh the goop is
coming gwyneth paltrow introduced a new
diamond-encrusted treponation drill and
drainage bucket on her website with just
a few cranks this elegant stainless
steel drill can pierce through the
thickest part of your cranial bone in
seconds leading to instant relief from
evil demons ghosts and spirits
possessing the soul on the description
of goop.com they actually use drills
like this in like the neural icu or a
neurosurgery but why gweneth paltrow has
anything to do with this is just like
satanic woman puts off going to doctor
until disease is bad enough for him to
believe her i'd love to get an
appointment soon but it's just easier if
i show up sick enough to force his hand
to actually give me the correct medical
care i want to laugh but it's more sad
than anything doctors misunderstand
women and because they misunderstand
women they end up not believing women i
think it's it's a issue of training and
the lack of experience to working with a
diverse patient population and you need
to be able to be ready for it and adjust
and be able to communicate with all
different types of patients doctors
recommend getting eight centuries of
crime sleep this could be a headline
from the future or it could be a
headline for these biohackers and boy
have these biohackers gotten on my
nerves make sure to forego caffeine and
silence your phone before replacing your
blood with medical grade anti-freeze
there's some good advice here like
foregoing caffeine good advice getting
your phone out of the room good advice
and the number one sleep thing that i
tell people all the time no more than
15-20 minutes of trying to fall asleep
in bed otherwise get out of the bed go
try and fall asleep on the couch read a
book because the more you struggle in
bed the more you associate all those
negative feelings and that anxiety with
the bed as opposed to getting tired
elsewhere and wanting and craving your
bed so the moment you touch you can fall
asleep into a soundful
cdc unveils list of twitter accounts you
can follow to piece together vaccine
information following these reporters
medical researchers and politically
engaged musicians
will provide the updates necessary to
cobble together some sense of what
exactly is going on with our vaccine
rollout this is probably the most
accurate onion article we're gonna see
because i feel like the cdc is an
amazing organization rich with brilliant
individuals but somehow they fail to
consider the importance of a proper
communications department when certain
decisions are made give the reasoning
for why those decisions are made if they
change explain there is the reasons for
the change and when you ask people to do
their own research it's going to lead
them to go onto facebook and see all
these crazy things that maybe some of
their friends are posting
do you know what detox teas do to your
health click here to find out as always
stay happy and healthy be really curious
what you think about this video because
in it i tell the honest truth not just
the truth the honest truth
[Music]